this is a murder weapon this particular
one Stephen get somewhere near that
Center Jim who's firing the musket was
one until he retired was one of our
senior technicians like near bombs and
Tim used to let off explosives and do
experiments just like Neil does now but
Neil doesn't have a license to handle
firearms so we've specially invited Jim
to come back so he can fire the musket
well this this demonstration I saw one
that's been done it here not in
university for very many years and first
originated by a quite a character called
Colonel sure the firing of the musket is
a very old experiment the first
reference I found to it was in the 18th
century when the Scottish Explorer James
Bruce fired a candle from his musket to
show the Emperor of Ethiopia that he
really meant business and his gun was
good he fired it through a shield first
time but shields were expensive so when
he repeated the experiments he was told
to do it through a table because tables
were more disposable and it goes without
saying that apparently was common in
days gone by that you could fire a wax
candle through a barn door and we
thought we'd put this to the test the
interesting scientific point is that
although wax can bend quite easily if
you fire it very rapidly it behaves like
a solid object and it's not much
different from lead or other bullets are
we taking powder granules from which the
energy is going to come from which is
gunpowder of black powder gunpowder is a
mixture of three chemicals testing
nitrate sulfur and charcoal the
experiment was feint made famous at
Nottingham by Colonel Biddy Shaw who was
a chemistry lecturer here for many many
years
and demonstrated this experiment for
more than 60 years from 1928 right up
till 1919
we've got the Gunpowder down into the
barrel of the the weapon and hold that
there
we're gonna put a wad in this is cotton
wool soon would have used in the day
gramma firmly down hold that in place
[Music]
now to follow the saying we're going to
use our bullet which is a wax candle or
section of ordinary wax candle and that
goes down that's our bullet and hold the
bullet in place another what you see
this is quite a time-consuming yes
occupation for soldier of those days
this is a newer weapon this particular
one Biddy saw was a hundred in 1998 and
we had the special party for him and the
musket was fired in his honor and you
can see here is one of the pieces of
wood with his hundredth birthday as a
target and he is signed it here you can
see in this one that the candle was
going rather sideways so instead of
having a round hole you've got a slot
we've got the the chamber of the other
weapon here which is now loaded with the
black powder a wad the bullet another
wad hold it up nice tightly down
I mean tend to ignite that by putting on
that nipple there that has a hole in it
a cushion cap that's a little bit
cushion cap little cylinder with in the
bottom of that cylinder there's a small
amount of detonating explosives now that
when that goes on there and the hammer
comes down I pull the trigger
sends a flame down there into the
chamber of the weapon ignites the black
powder which then converts itself
rapidly into hot gases and expanding
rapidly with heat lots of heat which
always entertained drives that bullet
out with some considerable energy which
we were going to demonstrate sure
look at the target please our barn door
today is a series of pieces of plywood
there's a piece of plywood and then
there's a piece flywheel hole in it and
nothing therefore solid pieces of
plywood they're going quite a
substantial bond or in the second
lecture theater the candle went so
sideways that it never actually went
through the wood and you can see here if
the wax is just embedded itself in the
wood here we go I'm gonna put the
cushion cap on double [ __ ] it goes on to
there just remind you cushion cap ignite
powder expansion right ago that it's
about how gunpowder is an explosive that
explodes quite gently it gives a good
push to the candle so it comes out nice
and smoothly if you put in a high
explosive inside at such a gun there'd
be a bang and the whole thing would fly
into tiny pieces seven get somewhere
near that Center
I think that's a fairly near the center
let's go and see what damage we've done
so it's the saying was true all the way
through you can fire a white candle
through a bond or the sayings truth I
don't know I probably seen it more than
a hundred times BD Shaw used to
demonstrate this lecture a huge number
of times the year he retired 1965 he did
the election 135 times in one year but
as he got towards the end of his career
he put more and more gunpowder into
these things so the explosions got
bigger and bigger and eventually we were
too frightened for him to go on very
satisfying how did it make you feel
[Laughter]